nella city ragazzi ebbene questo video
sono vari generi ed oggi siamo soria
loro storie si continua a guardare lo
schermo questa schermata di gioco però
sia un attimino su tipo quello con lo
schermo così ecco che cazzo è quello se
se mangi le cose col ketchup c'è un
tovagliolo per fornire di iniziare a sto
punto ragazzi prima di vedere ok
facciamo new perfetto allora ma la
presente bene il chip credo sia tipo di
house una roba del genere più o meno su
quello stile game of presence a john
l'ex production cosa lei cast john le
carrè cas o le castagne gas real horror
story mica che entro questa cosa mi fa
cagare addosso fantastico
rappresentazione non pensavo stories the
law of the dark forest e la storia delle
storie parlano di una foresta oscura
molti hanno perso la loro vita qui avrei
coraggio anche tu rientra nella foresta
oscura guarda vico via volevo andare a
casa però se devo proprio è interent al
profeta entriamo in questa foresta non
si sa perché non si sa come mai il tizio
non è a casa guardassi my little pony ma
è qui ma non importa tanto sta
gocciolando qualche fantastico amore ci
sono negozi è il bambino di prima che
che mangia i panini a catch up o non so
che cosa
a si accende sta roba dell'utilità di
accendere una candela che è tutto in
bianco e nero tranne il sangue la
candela fantastico a salve se starò a
una bambola e camille attimo perché non
capire ma buongiorno signora l'aiuto
attraversa la strada per caso no va da
sola visto cosa non si va beh io spengo
accendo clicco a caso a sé adesso non si
accende più non ha pagato la bolletta
non si accede più la candela contava era
la vecchia il primo cosa hanno ancora
capito ma una pettinata la mattina
perché non importante questa casa io
erano fatto un cazzo non è che ti passa
foto di full hd con cosa nasca data all
iphone
no perché troppo strana bay of madonna
c'è più traffico e sta foresta che è un
centro commerciale che cazzo adesso non
posso più che carla bambola fantastico
tra la bambina si anche la bobina piace
il catch up non sa cosa nota
era lei la bambina di prima lo sappia ci
avrei scommesso anche perché si capiva
tipo che cesta bambini
appello del figlio bautista 51 mi ha
stampato un cinque dita sullo schermo ma
non importa
john a salve e la vecchietta di prima
perché no perché sta piangendo tanto io
mi son preso l'infarto mica lei
dell'altalena che che c'è qualcosa che
non vanno
vuoi che ti spingono sa perché sta
piangendo sta con chi e sorrisi non soci
una che piange un'altalena vuota e c'è
qualcuno che ride non è che posso andare
avanti a cliccare l'altalena mentre
questa piangere
ecco chi cazzo è che rideva
c'è un altro che ti è passato giusto
dietro primi non so se te ne sei accorto
io me ne sono accorti invece vogliamo
rimanere così per 45 minuti mentre
finisci di piangere non lo so già la
signora per provare a tirare sul morale
le offro questa testa
non so sempre era per lei era per lei
non per me
mezz'ora di piagnistei è che quale
potrei farlo anche prima
lo so che cazzo è successo risposto no
vabbè dai un ora di pianto è riesplosa
eco si levano no non ci credo ce n'è
veramente non ha senso donna incinta
trovata macellata da un killer
sconosciuto ok c'è un'altra lordo
cliccare ancora potessi perfetti non ero
concentrato sullo schermo per grazia di
dio non perché sono i rumor torna ma
perché poi ho deciso di trani sta
foresta di ancora non l'ho capito che
bello rumore di budello mandato cosa
pizia fantastico cosa c'è dentro i ragni
più brutti che abbiamo mai visto nella
mia vita giuro un'altra un'altra candela
perfetto c'è anche un teschio c'è un
test non ne farò una ragione che c'è un
tetto del 4 e dell'imposta tempo al
parco giochi non più che cazzo corretti
in una foresta così se ci son che non
fermi nati non capita sta cosa
[ __ ] [ __ ] cosa è successo
che cazzo se ok annullare stavo
stampando il gioco a furia di toccarle
la budella di ostra celato l'intestino
fantastico
ok basta persona mi fa
[Musica]
la camera dei segreti è stata aperta
calmi
lo sa bene lo sapp e stavolta lo sapevo
che va beh stavolta lo sappiamo
questa no questa perfetta puntano a tua
sorella usa dove siamo fi cos'è sta roba
le monde 5 limoni anno demoni damon
stesse around in asse 5 demoni danzano
intorno a un cerchio perfetto mi fa mi
fa veramente piacere parte del cazzo che
volete in cerchio tipo casca la terra
tutti giù per terra ma me ne frega una
sega a cribbio ma qualche incredibile se
devo farlo ma ecco ok ok lo fa da
perfetto mezz'ora per forza puttanata
presenti poi senso io vado a piano terra
grazie all'ascensore perché c'è questo
sia per più calmo che al momento se mi
arriva qualcosa le botte le botte giuro
non è successo un cazzo fai allora
spiegatemi nuti italy sta stronzata
avete voglia di finirla prostituzione
infatti prima o poi perché non ne posso
ho preso 45 impartiamo hanno iniziato il
suo video grazie mille
ma è la e la mamma che sta facendo la
torta che insieme non ti cazzaro si è
preso male la sorella cavernicola
buongiorno gente ma non so ragazzi non
ancora che il ragazzo ci fanno di con
dio
ma se ami con il bambino sei amico dei
topi non sei amico dei topi ok va bene
ma bastava dirlo è ragazzo si è finiti
ragazzi a macchia questa bella donna vi
sdraiate non ho ancora capito denti zio
fester che continua a fare avanti
indietro la finiamo no perché mi sta
leggermente rompendo il cazzo è altro
che la pa da chris christie davanti
ragazzi e un tronco che respira cos'è
star non si capisce se una è un polipo è
un polipo che cazzo ci faceva un po il
live e lei zio fester incappucciato
novero cosa sta facendo si fa perché
andato e cosa sta facendo questa faccia
di chi dai ragazzi alzate le mani tutti
i principi la minetti gioco al coltello
la testa l'ha tagliato la testa a
fondarla posso prendere io ma cosa ha
fatto alzarsi non c'è la testa ragazze
alzata la tizia senza la non è normale
la testa effettivamente mi stava sul
culo però chiudiamo le finestre lì a
destra grazie io non ho fatto anche io
acceso semplicemente cose non date la
colpa né perché non fatto un cazzo mi fa
piacere che dovunque entry faccio casino
fantastico ma siamo a las vegas
no perché mi sembra tipo ok io non lo
tocco a prescindere non tocco quella
roba a terra sono conosci ovunque si può
più tardi no ditemi fate andare via di
qualche visto non prende abbastanza le
palle di stare su come anche lui sarà
rotto i [ __ ] mista ci togliamo dalle
balle
ora devo andare tu io che l'hanno
rottura di [ __ ] stare qui dove sto
andando io di preciso salve ci muoviamo
no perché non so cosa devo fare
c'è un amico e portare dirlo prima che
ne so sentite male so io ma mi devi
presentare tutta la classe quando vi
annoiate di stare appesi non lo so
magari giochiamo insieme se mi piaceva
tajana vanno bene non gli piace
battaglia navale mi dicono che non gli
piace che comincia a capire le cozze
fontenova vige come ti chiami tu c'eri
però il problema il problema e zio
fester un tiro avversario che il
[ __ ] da divenuto amico perché
dall'inizio che mi segue però va bene tt
cola un po il naso voglio un fazzoletto
non lo so mi sa che non lo vuole più il
falso detto paroli lancio giu cover in
seriamente che cazzo era propizio susa
scegli scegli cosa scelgo tipo la roba
come matrix pillola rossa pirola blu è
più bella la pillola questa credo sono
tutte uguali che cazzo ne so andiamo a
destra che cazzo scelto siamo ok sono
usciti sono uscito questo all'inizio
senza bambole senza ketchup senza niente
l'ho fatta lega cioè sei vivo e sei
scappato dal tormento della golia
dell'inferno di questi arrivi l'incubo
queste queste canzoni mostruose ora sono
soltanto un ricordo se qualcosa riuscirà
a prenderti prima o poi di sicuro mia
nonna quando le dico che non ho fame se
scegliamo la pillola sbagliata cioè nel
culo però fortunatamente ho scelto
quella giusta ma per ragazzi dire che
posso concludere qui perche ne posso più
di quel tizio che continua a andare
avanti indietro comunque e video è
piaciuto come al solito lasciato
commento mi piace anche a baia di
facebook che come ogni video tratte
nella descrizione se lo stand e prestiti
iscrivetevi di ci vedranno prossimo vito
cortese ragazzi